a heavy police response just outside of
nellis air force base tonight after a
plane crash is killing the pilot
thank you for joining us tonight at 11
i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez this was not a
military aircraft but one from a company
that actually operated out of the base
we are told the plane went down just
about 2 30 this afternoon on north
christie lane which is not too far from
lake mead and nellis orco mana joining
us live there now with the very latest
on this investigation
orco well brian and denise nellis air
force base says the plane that crashed
was a contractor operated aircraft it
took off from nellis
and then went down in this area this
afternoon near the southern edge of the
base there's still a heavy police and
military
presence blocking off this part of north
christie lane as investigators try to
piece together
what happened it just went
boom and all at once it just flipped
right straight down nose down
a scary situation near nellis air force
base witnesses describing the moments a
plane crashed in their northeast valley
neighborhood monday afternoon
the pilot did not survive fewer videos
showing the fiery aftermath
and black smoke billowing into the sky
didn't sound normal
you could tell there was something wrong
with it so i looked at it and it was
coming down
very fast and it was pretty low i'm
86 years old and i never seen anything
like that in my life only on tv
the ntsb says the plane that went down
was a dassault aviation mirage f1 that
looked similar to this
nellis air force base tells us it was a
contracted aircraft
that was owned operated and piloted by
draken us
a company that provides adversary air
support to nellis
drakken calling this a tragic loss of
one of their pilots as witnesses send
well wishes to those impacted
my prayers go out to the people to the
pilot you know
because you know it could have been us
right there you know witnesses add that
it seemed like some sort of trailer
caught fire once the plane crashed
and many say it's a day they will never
forget a lot of things i've seen in my
life that's probably
the number one thing that
scared me
the pilot's identity has not been
released yet and the cause of the crash
is still being determined
we're told no one else was on board the
plane and that draken is cooperating
with investigators the ntsb
does not get involved with military
incidents but they are investigating
this crash because they say
it was flown by a civilian be sure to
stay with eight news now both on air and
online
as we continue to learn more reporting
live tonight orco mana 8 news now
and following the tragic news clark
county commission chair marilyn
kirkpatrick releasing this statement
our houts our hearts go out to the
family and the friends of the pilot
today's tragedy is a reminder of the
important work being done
every day at nellis in defense of our
nation